después de estar expuesto a una máquina
electromagnética de encogimiento joe se
encogió un total de 120 centímetros en
1.5 segundos
su altura disminuyó en la misma
proporción cada segundo yo quiere saber
cuánto cambio a su altura cada segundo
cuál de las siguientes ecuaciones
describe mejor la situación
vamos a analizarlo lo que nos dicen es
que joe encogió un total de 120
centímetros disminuyó 120 centímetros en
su altura en 1.5 segundos ese es el
tiempo que pasó en el cual disminuyó
esta altura estos 120 centímetros
entonces esta expresión la primera que
nos dan menos 1.5 no tiene mucho sentido
en cuanto a la situación porque estos
1.5 se refieren al tiempo a los segundos
y pues como que no podemos tener
segundos negativos no podemos retroceder
en el tiempo
esta no expresa el sentido de la
situación lo que pasó es que en el
tiempo de 1.5 segundos
la cantidad positiva de tiempo joe
disminuyó - restó 120 centímetros a su
estatura esta es la expresión que mejor
representa esta situación así que
elegimos esta como respuesta no elijo
ninguna de las anteriores porque ya
encontré una opción que se ajusta a lo
que me describen aquí hagamos otro
problema
la cuenta de cash por usar su celular
fue de 79.99 al mes durante tres meses
sus pagos salieron de su cuenta de
cheques
la ecuación siguiente describe la
situación aquí la cuenta fue de 79.99 al
mes es decir le cobraron o le restaron
de su cuenta de cheques 79.99 que es
esta cantidad durante tres meses estos
son tres meses así que menos 79.99 por
tres es igual a menos 239 punto 97 que
nos dice a qué se refiere este menos 239
punto 97
este de acá elige todas las opciones
correctas
el cambio total en la cuenta de cheques
de cash como resultado de los tres pagos
fue de menos 239 punto 97 es cierto todo
lo que había en la cuenta de cheques de
acas disminuyó esta cantidad como
resultado de sus tres meses de pagos así
que esta si no sirve 239 puntos 97
fueron tomados de la cuenta de cheques
de acas para pagar el teléfono podría
ser
si nos represente esto pero tendrían que
agregar los aquí que este pago fue un
total de tres meses no esta cantidad
cada mes entonces pues está como que no
está muy completa para describir la
situación veamos otro problema más
el bidé comenzó a ejercitarse hace
cuatro semanas cuatro semanas de tiempo
y desde entonces ha perdido uno y medio
kilogramos cada semana la ecuación
siguiente describe la situación - ya que
perdió uno y medio kilogramos por semana
durante cuatro semanas estas cuatro
semanas de aquí y menos un medio por
cuatro es igual a menos seis y nos
preguntan este menos seis que nos dice
elige todas las opciones correctas
hevia y perdió seis kilos cada semana no
aquí nos están diciendo que cada semana
ella perdió uno y medio kilos los seis
kilos en una semana
todo esto estos seis kilos fueron el
resultado de cuatro semanas de
ejercitarse así que esta no es 10 subió
6 kilos en total no nos están diciendo
un mes
perdió kilos no subió así que esa
tampoco es por lo tanto voy a poner que
es ninguna de las anteriores